We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Gertis said that architecture is frozen music. That's lovely.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。歌德曾说，建筑是凝固的音乐。这很美妙。
Of course, that was before audio recording. So now for the most part, music is frozen music. It's only very recently in the history of music that we've been able to freeze music into an object. And in my life, the form of this object mattered a lot. I once bought vinyl albums and cassette tapes, and there were two first songs per album, Side A and Side B. The energy of a first song made it stand apart from the other songs, at least in my head it did. Then the CD came along and eliminated Side B and
当然，那是在录音技术出现之前。所以现在，在很大程度上，音乐就是凝固的音乐。在音乐史上，我们能够将音乐“冻结”成一个实体，这还是最近才发生的事。在我的一生中，这种实体的形式非常重要。我曾经买过黑胶唱片和卡带，每张专辑都有两首“第一首歌”，即A面和B面。第一首歌的能量让它在其他歌曲中脱颖而出，至少在我的脑海里是这样。后来CD出现了，它消除了B面，
there was only one first song and the actual number of the track that you could see prominently displayed on the CD player UI. That became my index for sorting songs. Then MP3s jumbled my sense of track order and albums began to feel more like a loose group being of individual pieces rather than a conceptual whole. I could do this all day and you're welcome to chime in, let's just totally hash this out on the website. But my point is this, when it comes to music, the form of the thing matters. But no effect has been as world-changing as the original innovation, freezing music in time onto a recording,
只剩下一首第一首歌，而且你可以在CD播放器的界面上清晰地看到曲目的实际编号。那成了我整理歌曲的索引。后来MP3打乱了我对曲目顺序和专辑的感觉，专辑开始感觉更像是一堆松散的单曲集合，而不是一个概念整体。我可以整天谈论这个，也欢迎你们加入讨论，我们完全可以在网站上彻底探讨一下。但我的观点是，当谈到音乐时，事物的形式很重要。但没有任何影响能像最初的创新那样改变世界，即把音乐冻结在录音中，
where a single version of a song, a single performance of a song, became the song. This inherently mutable method of communication was fundamentally changed. Songs are astonishing things and I also don't think most people really even know what they are. That's the songwriter composer, Amperie's or John Bryant. Now I didn't talk to John Bryant, but I know people who did. Jim DeRugatus and Greg Cot are the hosts of a radio program I'm a huge fan of, called Sound Opinions. It's a rock and roll talk show. And if certain niche-y snarky corners of the internet have darkened your concept of
在那里，一首歌的单一版本、单一表演，就成了这首歌本身。这种本质上可变的交流方式被彻底改变了。歌曲是令人惊叹的东西，而且我认为大多数人甚至不知道它们到底是什么。那是词曲作者、作曲家乔恩·布莱恩（Jon Brion）。我没有和乔恩·布莱恩交谈过，但我认识和他交谈过的人。吉姆·德罗加蒂斯（Jim DeRogatis）和格雷格·科特（Greg Kot）是我非常喜欢的广播节目《声音观点》（Sound Opinions）的主持人。这是一个摇滚乐谈话节目。如果互联网上某些小众、刻薄的角落让你对
music journalism, well, Sound Opinions is your beacon of light, my friends. Anyway, John Bryan came to WBZ in Chicago to talk to his own opinions in 2006. And at the time, Bryan had just co-produced Kanye West's album Late Registration, and he was also already well known as a film composer of a lot of really great movies, many by Paul Thomas Anderson. I heard the show broadcast on WBZ while I was sitting in my car in a parking lot of Atakaria in Logan Square, and I've thought about this section of their interview about songs versus performances, at least once a month since then.
音乐新闻产生了阴暗的看法，那么，《声音观点》就是你们的指路明灯，朋友们。总之，乔恩·布莱恩在2006年来到芝加哥的WBEZ电台谈论他的观点。当时，布莱恩刚刚联合制作了坎耶·韦斯特（Kanye West）的专辑《Late Registration》，而且他作为许多伟大电影的电影配乐师已经很有名了，其中许多电影是由保罗·托马斯·安德森（Paul Thomas Anderson）执导的。我当时坐在洛根广场一家塔克饼店的停车场里，在车里听到了WBEZ广播的这个节目，从那时起，我每个月至少会想起他们采访中关于“歌曲与表演”的这一部分一次。
For six years, but only recently did it on me that this is a perfect 99% of visible story. So here it is. John Bryant on Sound Opinions in 2006. I distinguish between what, for lack of better terms, I call songs and performance pieces. And what most people like are specific performances. We've grown up in an era of recording. And you know, the very thing, one of the very things I love recording has killed people's ability to hear songs purely as core change Melody and lyric. It's a very strange and beautiful art form because when it's right boy, do you know it?
整整六年了，但直到最近我才意识到，这是一个完美的《99%隐形》故事。所以，这就是2006年乔恩·布莱恩在《声音观点》节目中的谈话。我区分了——由于缺乏更好的术语——我称之为“歌曲”和“表演作品”的东西。大多数人喜欢的是特定的表演。我们在录音时代长大。你知道，我所热爱的东西之一，正是录音技术，它扼杀了人们纯粹以和弦变化、旋律和歌词来聆听歌曲的能力。这是一种非常奇特而美丽的艺术形式，因为当它恰到好处时，天哪，你是知道的。
But what we have sort of lost is I don't know the best example I could probably give would be lead Zeppelin Those things are the ultimate performance pieces, and I'm a big fan. I think they're just absolutely astonishing, and the sort of dynamics they had are sorely lacking in music today. Record making is great. A true band in the sense that you really could tell who the individuals were. A remarkable thing. And I don't consider most of those things songs.
但我们失去的是——我不知道最好的例子可能就是齐柏林飞艇乐队（Led Zeppelin）。那些是终极的表演作品，我是他们的忠实粉丝。我认为他们绝对令人惊叹，他们所拥有的那种动态在今天的音乐中严重缺失。唱片制作很棒。他们是一个真正的乐队，那种你真的能分辨出谁是谁的乐队。一件了不起的事情。而且我不认为那些东西中的大多数是“歌曲”。
And the way I can sort of prove my point is, have you ever listened to anybody else play a Led Zeppelin song and gone, oh, that was a great satisfying experience. Except for Dread Zeppelin, who I'd love. What people like is that specific guitar sound, that specific performance in concert with that specific drum sound, with that specific drummer playing that specific part. And it's beautiful, it's a beautiful thing.
我证明自己观点的方法是，你有没有听过别人演奏齐柏林飞艇的歌，然后觉得，哦，那是一次很棒、很满足的体验？除了我喜欢的“恐怖齐柏林”（Dread Zeppelin）乐队之外。人们喜欢的是那种特定的吉他音色，那种特定的表演，配合那种特定的鼓声，以及那个特定的鼓手演奏那个特定的部分。这很美，这是一件美妙的事情。
They're all different types of art and creative expression. However, if I were to sit and go, here, over on the piano, go, this is the melody to a Led Zeppelin song. And I could play, you know, 30 others that that's the thing. You know, I know it could sound like a snobbishness. It's not. I'm telling you, I love these records. They're great. However, it is, there's a difference between that and a song, say, a Gershwin song, you could actually play in the style of Led Zeppelin and have a completely satisfied experience. I do it all the time. I want to hear that. But when you start playing Zeppelin's song, say, in the style of like 1920s music,
它们都是不同类型的艺术和创造性表达。然而，如果我坐下来，弹着钢琴说，这是齐柏林飞艇歌曲的旋律。我可以弹奏，你知道，其他30首，这就是重点。你知道，我知道这听起来可能有点势利。其实不然。我告诉你，我喜欢这些唱片。它们很棒。然而，这与一首歌是有区别的，比如一首格什温（Gershwin）的歌，你实际上可以用齐柏林飞艇的风格来演奏，并获得完全满足的体验。我经常这样做。我想听那个。但当你开始用比如1920年代音乐的风格演奏齐柏林飞艇的歌时，
it's suddenly it's laid bare that it's like, oh no, it was about those people. And those people were in a room and it was, and it was great. And I love it. But I consider it a performance piece. And I consider a lot of rock the people listen to be performance pieces. They're not necessarily songs. I heard you had Tom York here recently and there's a guy who's a songwriter, comes into the band and goes, here's the thing I've got, and then they rock with holy hardness and
突然间，真相大白了，你会觉得，哦不，那是因为那些人。那些人在一个房间里，这很棒。我喜欢它。但我认为它是一件表演作品。我认为人们听的很多摇滚乐都是表演作品。它们不一定是歌曲。我听说你最近请到了汤姆·约克（Thom Yorke），他是一个词曲作者，他带着东西来到乐队，说，这是我有的东西，然后他们以神圣的力度和
all the greatness they've got with them getting in a room. I mean, you know, that's part of what makes a band like Radiohead stand out. You know, when that second record came out, we all collectively went, oh my god! Somebody who actually has songs in this guy's an amazing singer! It isn't extinct yet. Yeah, and... Or Cobain, right? Right! Exactly, and I mean, okay, here. Let's uh... The little musicology course. Okay, if you just go, yeah, it was cool. It was, you know, punk rock.
他们所拥有的所有伟大之处在房间里一起摇滚。我的意思是，你知道，这就是让电台司令（Radiohead）这样的乐队脱颖而出的原因。你知道，当第二张唱片出来时，我们都集体惊呼，天哪！有人真的有歌曲，而且这家伙是个了不起的歌手！它还没有灭绝。是的，还有……或者科本（Cobain），对吧？对！没错，我的意思是，好吧，这里。让我们……上一门小小的音乐学课程。好吧，如果你只是说，是的，这很酷。它是，你知道，朋克摇滚。
It was popular. He had it factor for days. But if you take the average punk rock sound, it is that same lead Zeppelin melody, even though they hated Zeppelin so much. It's very hard. No, but if it's like... You know, one of a thousand punk songs. Sure.
它很流行。他有那种魅力。但如果你采用普通的朋克摇滚声音，它就是同样的齐柏林飞艇旋律，尽管他们非常讨厌齐柏林飞艇。这很难。不，但如果它是……你知道，成千上万首朋克歌曲中的一首。当然。
There's a big difference between that and... Hmm. I mean, I can sit here on Grand Piano playing unaffected version and we can all go, oh my god, yeah, that's the best thing ever. Yeah. And my spine tingles any time I play that melody over those chord changes. That to me, lithium is no different. It's in the same realm as being able to go, you know, where, you know, probably like most people, I remember exactly where
这和……嗯，有很大的区别。我的意思是，我可以坐在这里弹奏大钢琴，演奏一个不受影响的版本，我们都可以说，哦天哪，是的，这是有史以来最好的东西。是的。每当我弹奏那些和弦变化上的旋律时，我的脊椎都会发麻。对我来说，涅槃乐队的《Lithium》没有什么不同。它和能够说，你知道，在哪里，你知道，可能像大多数人一样，我记得我第一次听到《Lithium》时
I was first time I heard lithium. I remember back of the friends car and it came on and I just freaked out. I mean, I was nearly in tears. I'm like, oh my God, that guy is better than everybody's. He's like, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's true.
我在哪里。我记得在朋友的车后座，它响了起来，我简直疯了。我的意思是，我差点流下眼泪。我想，天哪，那家伙比所有人都强。他说，是的。是的。是的。这是真的。
Yeah. You know, it was so palpable. Like, that's one of the best chord changes I've ever heard. It's absolutely as good as, you know, Gershwin or Thelonius Monk or any great thing that's existed. It was John Bryan, talking with Jim DeRigadas and Greg Cot on Sound Opinions in 2006. Sound Opinions is produced by WBEZ Chicago and distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Find out more at Sound Opinions.com. I'm not sure if I can do it. I'm not sure if I can do it.
是的。你知道，它太明显了。就像，那是我听过的最好的和弦变化之一。它绝对和格什温或塞隆尼斯·蒙克（Thelonious Monk）或任何存在过的伟大作品一样好。这是乔恩·布莱恩在2006年的《声音观点》节目中与吉姆·德罗加蒂斯和格雷格·科特的谈话。《声音观点》由芝加哥WBEZ制作，并由公共广播交易所PRX发行。欲了解更多信息，请访问 SoundOpinions.com。我不确定我能不能做到。我不确定我能不能做到。
I'm not sure if I can do it. I'm not sure if I can do it. I'm not sure if I can do it. 99% Invisible was produced this week, pretty much by sound opinions. Special thanks to Robin Wynn and Jason Saldonna. We are a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. Support for 99% of visible is provided in part by the Facebook design team who believes that design can bring positive change to the world.
我不确定我能不能做到。我不确定我能不能做到。我不确定我能不能做到。《99%隐形》本周的节目基本上是由《声音观点》制作的。特别感谢罗宾·温（Robin Wynn）和杰森·萨尔多纳（Jason Saldonna）。我们是旧金山KALW-91.7当地公共广播电台以及旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。《99%隐形》的支持部分来自Facebook设计团队，他们相信设计可以为世界带来积极的改变。
Visit them at facebook.com slash design. And by tiny letter, email for people with something to say. My boy Carver always says something to say. What do you have to say, Carver? I think that my dad is the best. Well you know like if I put that on everyone's gonna say, oh Roman, you just made your son say that he's the best. Are you the best? What do you have to say about that? Can you tell you the list about how to also filmed?
请访问 facebook.com/design。还要感谢Tiny Letter，为有话要说的人提供的电子邮件服务。我的孩子卡弗（Carver）总是说有话要说。你有什么要说的吗，卡弗？我认为我爸爸是最棒的。好吧，你知道，如果我把它放出来，每个人都会说，哦罗曼，你只是让你儿子说他是最棒的。你是最棒的吗？你对此有什么要说的吗？你能告诉我关于如何拍摄的列表吗？
It's the simplest way to write an email newsletter tinyletter.com from the people behind male chip. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars and I'm serious let's talk about how the objects of music change the way you both make and listen to music. I'm ready to throw down at 99% of visible. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是编写电子邮件通讯最简单的方法，tinyletter.com，来自Mailchimp背后的人。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我在推特上是@RomanMars，我是认真的，让我们谈谈音乐实体是如何改变你创作和聆听音乐的方式的。我准备在《99%隐形》中大干一场。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。